let's head back to Paris now where there
have been some developments following
that deadly shooting we've been
reporting on you can see the live
pictures there a bit of disturbances it
seems or excitement that at least going
on in the streets the dashabata is there
for us Natasha take us through what's
happening looks like a lot of angry
people right now
behind me are many people from paris's
Kurdish community and they are very
upset because they feel that the
shooting that took place here a bit
earlier today was targeted specifically
at them because the shooter opened fire
in a street where there was a Kurdish
Center but there was also a restaurant
there was also a hairdressers but people
here really do feel that perhaps that
shooting was against them against their
Community they say they're not being
protective it's a lot of anger here
people are chanting things against
turkey against the Turkish president's
erdogan and someone a short time ago
just said bye
Natasha this is what's on Reuters news
agency quoting the French interior
Minister Gerard
saying that he appears the suspect
appears to have had racist motivations
are we getting any more details about
what the motive of the attack or or
about the suspect himself
[Music]
I think there's just been some takeouts
from police there so if we have to move
we will but what we know and what the
French term Minister has said is that it
does seem as if there could have been a
racist motivation for this attack this
suspect was known to police in fact in
2021 he was charged for a suspected
attack on some migrants in a migrant
camp in the center of Paris so that's
what we've heard from the French
interior Minister also from the Paris
prosecutor and this is you know this
area in the center of Paris is a very
Multicultural area there are people from
all different communities but as I said
really what we have here is mainly
paris's Kurdish Community who feel very
upset indeed because this attack took
place outside a Kurdish Center and they
really feel that they specifically were
targeted even though that hasn't been
confirmed by police
of course
years ago we did see attacks in Paris
they were investigated or framed as
terrorist incidents especially where the
suspect was of a migrant immigrant or
Muslim background how is this being
investigated by police so far
[Music]
the tax in France by people of Muslim
backgrounds have of course
I'm just looking out as people are
starting to throw things not all of them
have been more framed necessarily as
terrorist incidents some of them have
been
in the past some have been framed as
Lone Wolf incidents I think that's how
foreign
[Music]
let's let you take cover we'll come back
to you later bye well I I can I can
we don't want to keep you In Harm's Way
Natasha so if you need to move all right
maybe we should move on we'll let
Natasha take cover we'll come back to a
little later I am no I'm here if you
need me
right well I'll let you I'll let you
make the call all right we're going to
make the call actually so we'll let this
I should take some cover there